حرب المسيرات على جانبي الحدود مرحله
جديده تدخلها المعارك بين كييف وموسكو ذا
كما كان جليا في تصاعد هجمات الطائرات
المسيره على اهداف داخل الاراضي الروسيه
بالجرود جنوب غربي روسيا لا تكاد تنطفئ
نيران الهجمات هنا حتى تشتعل مجددا فخلال
يوم واحد فقط ضربت 155 قذيفه منطقه
الشبكيينو في مقاطعه بيلغرود ومن اقوى
هجمات الساعات الاخيره تلك التي استهدفت
مصفاه لتكرير النفط في اقليم كراش نودار
في جنوب روسيا لا تبعد كثيرا عن ميناء
نوفروسيسك الروسي على البحر الاسود حيث
هاجم الطائره مسيره مصفاه لتكرير النفط
غرب مدينه كريستنودار عاصمه الاقليم ما
ادى لاندلاع حريق بمضخه للديزل على مساحه
100 متر مربع مسيره ثانيه حاولت ضربه
منشاه السكي لتكرير النفط غرب مدينه
كرسنودار ايضا
لكنها اسقطت قبل بلوغ وجهتها بحسب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وسبق ان تعرضت منشاه السكي
النفطيه هذه لاكثر من ثلاث هجمات بمسيارات
خلال شهر مايو وفي هجوم اوسع هاجمت عشر
طائرات مسيره منطقه كليموفيسك بمقاطعه
بيريانسك الروسيه المتخيمه للحدود مع
اوكرانيا تقول السلطات المقاطعه ان محطات
الرادار الالكترونيه اسقطت عددا من
المسيرات المهاجمه وبالتزامن مع هجوم
المسيرات تتعرض نقطه تفتيش حدوديه في
مقاطعه بيريانس لهجوم مسلح حدث ذلك تحديدا
عند حاجز بروج الحدودي لعبور السيارات
تتهم السلطات المواليه لروسيا القوات
الاوكرانيه بانها من قامت باطلاق النار
هذه الهجمات تاتي بعد ساعات من هجوم غير
مسبوق في حجمه شانه سرب من ثماني طائرات
مسيره على العاصمه الروسيه موسكو وخلافا
لجميع هذه الهجمات كان هجوم الثالث من
مايو اكثرها خطوره اذ اعلنت السلطات
الروسيه اسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين خلال
محاولتهما مهاجمه هذا الهجوم كان فاتحه
لهجمات شبه يوميه في العمق الروسي منذ
بدايه مايو برا وجوا 100 كييف بنفسها عن
معظم هذه الهجمات مشيره الى انها بفعل
جماعات مناوئه للكرملين وفقا لما تعلنه
السلطات في موسكو فان الطائرات من دون
طيار من طراز يوجي 22 تشن جل الهجمات فهي
سلاح مفضل لمهاجمه اهداف روسيه بعيدا عن
ميدان المعركه في اوكرانيا تصنع هذه
الطائرات في اوكرانيا ومداها يصل الى 800
كيلومتر ما يجعلها قادره على الوصول الى
موسكو وما وراءها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تتحدث كذلك عن هجمات بالطائرات المسيره
البريطانيه من طراز 150 وهي طائرات
تستخدمها مشاه البحريه الملكيه البريطانيه
يمكنها حمل حتى 68 كيلو جراما وتستطيع
الطيران حتى 70 كيلومترا تدخل صواريخ
ستورم شادو البريطانيه اتونا الحرب وقد
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط عدد
منها دون ان تفصح عن تفاصيل مكان الهجوم
يبلغ مدى ستورم شادو اكثر من 250 كيلومترا
وتتميز بقدراتها على تدمير اي هدف تصيبه
بدقه اما في عمليات التوغل البري فكان
لافتا حضور المدرعات المضاده للكمائن
والالغام امراب الامريكيه الصنع والتي
ظهرت خلال هجوم بري نفدته قوات مواليه
لكييف داخل الاراضي الروسيه وفقا لوسائل
اعلام روسيه صنعت مركبه امراب للمره
الاولى لخدمه القوات الامريكيه في العراق
وافغانستان وزودت الولايات المتحده الجيش
الاوكراني بعده مئات منها